une pyramide de verre dans la cour
Napoléon au Louvre pour contempler
peut-être les 20 siècles à
venir en tout cas un travail de Romain
où pour aménager tous les sous-sols de
cet espace il aura fallu sortir 400000 m
C de
terre dans 6 mois seule la pyramide sera
visible et dans les parois de verre se
reflèteront les façades du plus grand
musée du monde et le soleil et les
nuages qu mins piliers supporteront à
eux seul les 35 tonnes de l'édifice et
cela représente un exploit technique
comparable à celui des pharaons lorsque
il y a 4000 ans ils bâtirent leur
pyramide au sud du
Ken avec cette pyramide
le lour aura une entrée digne des
chedœuvres qu'il renferme et dans
quelques mois on saura si les milliers
de F moderne avec leur machine on bien
travailler